hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
near the end of section 3 of the
groundwork of the metaphysics of morals
Conte is going to talk about what he's
calling a dialectic of reason and it's
worth exploring just what the dialectic
gives but before that let's talk about
the meaning of this term for Conte
because they think that some people may
associate this with some of the
philosophers coming after count on the
one hand and other people may associate
it with some of the Philosopher's coming
long before kaan on the other hand and
he doesn't mean what either of those
groups mean so on the you might say
front-end we have people like you know
Hegel and Marx who are coming after
conned Hegel is himself working in the
wake of Kahn she's part of the German
idealist movement that can't in many
respects kicks off and Marx is himself
building off of Hegel and as he says
turning Hegel on his head now for them
what dialectic means is this process by
which ideas are emerging out of each
other it's not necessarily the thesis
antithesis synthesis that a lot of
people make it out to be and in Hegel
but that that does happen for Marx
doesn't mean that he means something
different on the other hand on the back
end we can talk about Plato and
Aristotle and other ancient philosophers
for whom dialectic was this process of
back and forth discussion carried out by
rational beings which was supposed to
ultimately culminate in some sort of
scientific philosophical conclusions and
it began from starting points that might
be agreed to by most people they're not
entirely secure but eventually it was
supposed to yield our first principles
by which we would understand ourselves
the universe all sorts of other things
as well so that's very different than
the the second now what Kant means is
something quite different he
means sort of an interplay of reason the
rational faculty that we have but it's
actually something that can be carried
out by a person him or herself which
Aristotle said could be done as well and
it doesn't seem to yield a result so as
opposed to some sort of art or inquiry
which is supposed to produce results or
some sort of process which is supposed
to produce result instead for Kant a
dialectic is actually sort of a quagmire
right a place where it's difficult to
get through leads to operas not being
able to to proceed so why is there a
dialectic of reason happening here in
the groundwork one of the things that
Kant has been talking about is human
freedom and that is for him specifically
freedom of the will and if you look a
little bit earlier in the text and we
have some videos specifically on this he
is talking about the will as being
something that's ultimately grounded in
an intelligible world which science
can't get at experience can't get at
it's not a world of sense and that is
actually the grounding for the world of
synthesis the world of the understanding
or intelligible world and the will is
free of the sort of causal determination
that happens in the world of sense what
in this portion of the text
he's calling nature and Conte is going
to contrast here two different ways in
which the human being can be regarded
with respect to actions that's what
we're particularly interested in are our
actions
free or are they causally determined and
the answer is actually quite frankly
well it's both because the causal
determination is not simply the causal
determination of what's on this side the
side of necessity natural necessity but
on the side of the will as causally
determining our actions the will is its
own particular kind of cause that is not
caught up with
in the matrix of this sort of cause so
all of that set let's talk about what
the the two sides are on the one side we
have as he says the freedom of the will
and this is as you said an idea of
reason it is something that we can think
and in fact not only can we think it
inevitably we do in fact think it there
are some people who deny it of course in
order to deny it
they're already you know going against
what most people say and they are sort
of implicitly assuming it as Kant will
point out but it is something that we we
naturally you might say in exercising
our Faculty of Reason we'll arrive at
that it doesn't mean that we fully
understand it but it's something that we
can come up with and he says this is not
an empirical conception this is not
something that is coming to us from our
direct experience of the world or of our
own interior or 'ti as conscious beings
so there's something more going on here
on this side in the intelligible world
on the other side we have what Kant
calls the necessity of nature nature
operating according to laws now those
laws themselves are concepts of the
understanding right and this whole this
whole thing of the necessity of nature
that itself is a concept of the
understanding and the understanding is
not just the same thing as the senses it
is assembling them it is making its
integrating them into one consciousness
but this does as he says prove it it's
reality in experience the notion that
the natural world including our
consciousness insofar as it's part of
the natural world insofar as we are
acting within a world that includes all
these other things that's coherent we do
in fact experience that say for example
our motives that is our desires and
inclinations
nations do in fact move us to do things
they do in fact provide us with the
grounds for our actions not actions that
can thereby be say universalized
according to the categorical imperative
but but actions that we do follow
according to what Khan calls
hypothetical imperatives and we can see
other people doing the same thing and we
can see objects working in the same ways
and things in between us and mere
objects like say animals behaving in
that way so we have two different points
of view and we can say well you know one
way to resolve this is you know when
we're looking at ourselves as free
beings we're looking at this side and
when we're looking at ourselves as
beings whose actions are effects or
phenomena coming from other things that
we look at it this way so we have a
bifurcated point-of-view and Khan thinks
that that's fundamentally right but
there is a problem with that we're one
being and he says that these two
different perspectives have to be united
in the same thinking substance so not
only do we have you know the
understanding working on making sense of
what it is that we're experiencing
through the senses and you know
anteriorly through what we call the
inner sense and our consciousness and
trying to you know integrate and
synthesize all of this into one coherent
point of view we also have this entire
other side which reason is providing us
and we want to integrate that as well so
this is is representing a great you
might say metaphysical hope or desire on
the part of context he is recognizing
now the problem is that these two seem
to be in contradiction with each other
don't they if we look at it this way
then it seems like this has to be wrong
and if we look at it this way but it
seems that this has to be wrong why
would that be the case he doesn't fully
spell this out but if we think about
what the consequences are if we do
assume that that everything that that is
part of nature is operating
according to some sort of causal
necessity some sort of universal web of
determinism it seems like this can't
possibly be the case right on the other
hand we also think and Kant would say
even to some degree no you know by
following out our what reason tells us
at least in terms of the conceptions of
autonomy morality those sorts of things
that we this is something we do have to
take stock in so this is true if this
really is the case then doesn't that
undo the causal determinism every time I
make a free action doesn't that totally
bollocks things up and cut says here's
where we have to look at it again in two
different ways if we were thinking about
it merely in terms of what he calls
speculative philosophy which is
concerned with Pure Reason so this would
be you know the first critique the
critique of Pure Reason also his work
the prolegomena to any future
metaphysics then this is not something
that turns out to be resolvable yet it
is from the perspective of practical
philosophy and practical reason in fact
he goes further and he says it has to be
resolvable because if it's not then
something else is going to creep in
namely what he calls fatalism fatalism
is what we nowadays often call
determinism which is this notion that
there really is no human freedom in any
respect whatsoever that all things are
totally entirely determined by the same
sort of fabric of necessity which
operates according to laws which of
course we we can understand with a
little consolation there but we would
have no freedom whatsoever so the
resolution to this cut says cannot come
from the side of speculative philosophy
it must come from the side of practical
philosophy that is how this dialectic
can be addressed
you